foreign
is with us in New York City how can we
help today
Elizabeth Course in New York City I'm 34
years old I'm a social worker and I have
a son who's six years old right now I
only have one stream of income and I
have 300 roughly around 300 uh thousand
dollars worth of debt this is also
including student loans credit cards Etc
and I'm trying to prioritize what to
focus on first it's bringing on a lot of
anxiety
um I do make about 60 I believe 65 I got
a raise today actually and so I'm just
trying to figure out how I can beat that
free in a short amount of time take care
of you know my son have some saving I
can't save for anything and just live
comfortably uh that's the biggest thing
for me I did file for bankruptcy in 2018
and I was fine until I recently moved
this year
and uh the credit card debt stacked up
because of the move and I had some
medical issues so you know this year has
been a really tough uh and now I'm
struggling kind of
well we're glad you called that's first
step I feel like the way you're
describing that you've had your I've had
it moment is that right yeah definitely
yes you're done with this debt you're
ready for something new
totally I just want to live comfortable
I want my son to have his savings where
did you move from
well I'm actually from New York City but
I moved from a studio apartment to a
two-bedroom Co-op uh building so you're
broken deeply in debt and you increase
your rent
yes I did
but we needed the space
but you're broken deeply in debt and you
can't breathe
yeah oh and you run up credit card debt
to do that too
as of this summer yes it went up
yep
okay let's back out for a second
um
I can help you
all right but this is a math problem at
its core
and there's two pieces of information
here there's your income
and there's your debt load and around
here we call that the shovel
and the hole
you have a very large hole
and a medium-sized to small shovel
agreed
agree thus the anxiety
thus the stress the overwhelming feeling
the sense of hopelessness since I'm
going to be stuck here forever I can't
breathe I don't see a way out
I've been there I know how it feels
okay so you have a pretty radical
situation
a very difficult situation that you find
yourself in with the math
would you agree with that too
yes definitely the sad news is and um we
love you enough to tell you the truth
kiddo
uh the sad news is radical difficult
situations require radical difficult
Solutions
and the only way to get out of this
highly
toxic math is to do some bizarre things
that are going to be very uncomfortable
in the short term
you don't get an option
there's no option on the table where you
get to do three things
make sixty five thousand dollars a year
have a wonderful life and live in
Manhattan
these three things and and get rid of
three hundred thousand dollars for the
debt these three things these things
don't work in the same puzzle they don't
fit together
okay so something's going to give
something's going to give the you're
going to give up the cool cozy wonderful
life you're going to do some crazy
things to increase your income
um you're not going to live in Manhattan
I don't know
but you can't do what you're doing right
now it's not going to work in the next
two decades
you're still going to be in debt
because I can back this out and just
tell you if you had zero debt
living in Manhattan with a child as a
single mom on 65 000 is no picnic if you
had zero debt that's no picnic
agreed
agree and you got 300 000 bucks sitting
on top of your head
and uh it ain't going away
unless you make it go away so I I wish I
didn't
um
so I I think you're gonna pick your pain
or it's gonna pick you
um you're gonna pick your pain you're
gonna say all right we're going to live
in a different situation for a short
period of time and it's going to be very
uncomfortable for me and my child and
the hours I'm going to work are going to
be freaking ridiculous so that we can
have a great life later we're going to
live like no one else so that later we
can live and give like no one else or
you're going to choose to stay exactly
where you are and this stuff's going to
come crashing down on you because this
math does not work it's not sustainable
you can't pay for a co-op in Manhattan
on 65k and service 300 000. you can't
even pay the payments
and eat well um so the maintenance fee
so I do live in the Bronx the borough is
the Bronx and I had stuck out a loan
because it was 33 000 so it's like
pretty much it helps middle income uh
individuals with a co-op and so I put a
little bit down and I'm paying it off
um slowly I think I have like seven
years to pay off the loan that they gave
me
and then of course I have my Cardinal
credit card debt and student loan
private school loans as well
you bought the co-op
yes so I I bought the code and you have
a seven year loan on it
yeah well I can pay it off at any time
but I put a down payment on it
um it's it's like a program that helps
you uh pretty much are you telling me
you're gonna have to call it paid off in
seven years
I they add on the extra from the loan to
the maintenance fee yeah
yeah but I mean what happens at the end
of seven years you've got to go get a
mortgage right
it is pretty much a mortgage I am a
homeowner for that Co-op and you have it
on a seven year payout in the Bronx
I calculated it and I believe that's how
much it's gonna how long it's going to
take me to pay off that phone that they
gave me to cover the other half so that
I owe
so what was the price
uh altogether that Co-op apartment was
33
750. that was the price to buy a co-op
in the Bronx
yes
I am so confused
I would have said 3.3 million
how did you get it for 33 000 are you
sure
yeah so it's pretty much like I said
it's a program in New York City that
helps the middle uh income uh
individuals and they pretty much
um assist so you have to come up with
the whole you have to come up with the
whole amount and if you can't come up
with the whole amount uh then you can go
on a payment plan and then they'll add
it to your maintenance fee it's called a
maintenance fee thank you this is the
most Heavenly program I've ever heard of
where you can buy a co-op in the Bronx
for 33 000 bucks my mind is blown okay I
had no idea that this is even possible
or existed I am still in shock and awe
so anyway I guess I'll set that aside if
you got that deal I'll let it rest I
have never heard of that and it's
mind-blowing and it's has nothing to do
with real estate values in the area
nothing to do with that whatsoever you
can't buy that in anywhere in America
much less the freaking a borough of New
York one of the 18 boroughs in New York
City not a chance okay so all right I'll
let that rest we still have the 300 000
in debt well and I still have a problem
and I'm I'm worried you know when you
first picked up there's a lot of remorse
in your voice there's a lot of angst so
I thought you had that I had it moment
but I'm a little worried that the
bleeding's still going like have you cut
up your credit cards yet
I mean 300 000 that is that's a
terrifying amount on that on that income
okay so sharnice I don't want us to run
out of time here's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna have put you on how Laura's gonna
pick up we're gonna put you through
Financial Peace University as our guest
because I don't know how to help you on
this call today uh there's too much
going on here but you have a problem and
the problem is you don't make enough to
pay this debt off in a reasonable period
of time so something's got to give
on the income side of the equation and
it may mean you live in an entirely
different area of the nation